people see me and think they're safer
but it's not really me they're seeing
probably for the best
knowing everything hinges on a guy from
Queens sounds as scary as it feels
he's built pressure right
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so we got a big
surprise exclusive spider-man ps4 title
coming next year so let's break it down
the gameplay here is actually really
awesome this looks a lot like his fight
during the Captain America Civil War
sequence spider-man was really only in
that movie for like 10 to 20 minutes and
a little less than half of that was his
Peter Parker but you can see he's got
the white emblem his suit looks a little
more hardcore he's probably got some
more toys from Tony Stark so what's
going on with this game is it's ps4
exclusive the reason they didn't
announce a release date is because the
game isn't quite far long enough usually
it has to get to a certain point before
they know okay we're going to finish
this in six months or eight months but
they're probably going to do is drop the
game when it gets closer to the
spider-man movie which is coming next
summer so a lot of you are asking is
this game going to have anything to do
with the spider-man movie or the Marvel
franchise or the MCU yes and no the
story of the game won't be the same
story as the movie it's not going to be
one of those crappy movie tie-in games
those are the worst those are big cash
grabs the story of this will be original
but it will have Easter eggs for things
that are happening in the games you'll
have upgrades and skins based on the
stark tech that spider-man gets in the
movie remember Ironman is going to be in
the new spider-man movie he'll get some
new toys we'll probably see those in the
game so I'm not totally expecting Tom
Holland to be wearing the white emblem
suit that's in this game in the movie
they're not going to spoil the movie
with the game so yes Tom Hollands
spider-man suit will change just a
little bit but it'll still look pretty
close to the suit that he wore in Civil
War the rumor right now is that in the
movie he's going to get the webs
underneath his armpits and it's going to
look a little bit more like the classic
spider-man suit but like when you look
at the armor plates here it's still
going to be stark tech but it's gonna
look like a suit that a kid would wear
and could stuff in a gym bag so that's
the difference between spider-man suit
in like black panther's this made out of
vibranium weave would it be awesome
though if spider-man got a vibranium
weave suit I would not be surprised if
the game released some vibranium DLC
like after the movie comes out you get
extra DLC packs based on stuff that
happens in the movie but Marvel was
going crazy about this at e3 what the
game is is it's a collaboration between
insomniac games Sony and Marvel so
Marvel is heavily embedded in the
culture of spider-man at sony Sony still
owns the spider-man franchise but Marvel
is informing
where a lot of the creative goes so
story for the game all the things that
you're seeing the look and feel the way
it plays Marvel has a handed all that
Bendis is a huge gamer so I wouldn't be
surprised if when he heard they were
making a spider-man game he was pounding
on people's doors asking to help out but
let me know what you guys think of this
suit and which parts of New York do you
want to see in the game obviously Queens
is going to be a really big deal they're
gonna use the game to help create the
universe of spider-man
he's a street-level hero even though
he's been part of the Avengers so the
way his character fits into the Marvel
Universe is kind of like a cross between
like your big a-list Avengers like Iron
Man and Thor and then the street-level
Avengers like black widow or daredevil
you know people that don't have
superpowers because spider-man does have
superpowers but he's a little kid so
he's very inexperienced so it's like he
gets invited to the really big parties
but he has to take Tony Stark along as a
chaperone
please don't tell Aunt May speaking of
which actors appearing in the game I
know a lot of you always ask if the
actors from the movies are going to be
doing voices in the games because
they're working on the spider-man movie
right now
this isn't Tom Holland he's not doing
the voice for the game but when the game
comes out they'll probably do some fun
things because Tom Holland plays a lot
of video games even Robert Downey jr.
plays a lot of video games I don't think
there's anybody that stars in or makes
Marvel movies that does not play video
games so there'll be more stuff for the
game later this year probably like a
playable demo and then the game will
probably get released when we get closer
to the movie next year like spring of
next year but if they do an update or
they release some more bonus content
that ties in with the movies I'll be
sure to do a video about it but remember
at the end of civil war so careful for
spoilers from Civil War remember at the
end of that movie where he got the stark
tech web-shooters you'll see a lot of
stuff like that but you'll also see like
in this Queens Universe as you like fly
around the city you'll see Easter eggs
from the comic books places that
spider-man visited in comic book stories
really cool things that reward people
that spend a lot of time just poking
around the different corners of the game
so you always have your linear story
where it's like you know 2030 hours of
gameplay maybe 50 if it's like a JRPG
and then you have all this other free
roam stuff with side quests and stuff
the side quests are really where the
Easter Egg and the fun's out so let me
know what you guys think of the gameplay
some of these moves are actually
directly lifted from Captain America
Civil War like where he's fleeing this
big radiator around
you can just hear Falcon and Winter
Soldier just sitting off in the distance
just going I hate you so much that was
one of my favorite scenes from that
movie and speaking of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I just did a South
Park fractured but whole trailer video
if you don't know what that game is it's
a complete send up of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in the DC movies so
I'll put a link in the description it's
pure genius it's the most hilarious
thing ever but I know there's a lot of
Game of Thrones happening this week but
I'm also working on a spider-man movie
video for spider-man homecoming I'll
post that in a couple days they've
announced a couple more cast members so
there's a bunch of movie stuff to talk
about too while you guys wait for that
next video to post you can click here to
watch South Park completely roast Marvel
and DC and you can click here for my
Game of Thrones episode 9 trailer video
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you